Tear gas.
Is it an effective method for crowd control
or a toxic chemical weapon?
Hi everyone, I’m Reina, guest hosting on
DNews.
Tear gas, most commonly used for dispersing
unruly crowds is potentially more dangerous
than you think.
The key active ingredient, called 2 CHLOROBENZAL
MILONO NITRIL is a chemical that activates
large amounts of pain receptors in the eyes
and respiratory system by irritating the membranes.
This causes the eyes to start tearing and
closing involuntarily along with causing breathing
complications, which instantly incapacitates
you.
But that’s not all.
It can even cause chemical burns to exposed
skin, the breathing complications can mimic
a choking sensation which can lead to panic,
and that panic can lead to confusion and disorientation.
Most individuals that were hit with tear gas
used the word “pain” to describe their
experience.
An effective defense against tear gas is a
gas mask, but those aren’t easy to come
by.
Some protesters suggest making a make-shift
mask by soaking a bandana in lemon juice or
cider vinegar.
The acidified cloth supposedly helps block
the gas and should give you enough time to
flee the area.
But be aware that it’s not proven that this
method will work.
The worst part about tear gas is that treatment
after being exposed is virtually non-existent.
The best you can do is wash your eyes out
thoroughly, spit, cough, blow your nose, do
anything and everything to expel the chemicals
out of your body.
Medical experts also suggest taking a cold
shower because warm water can open your pores
and allow for the toxic particles to seep
further into your body.
Some suggest using saline solutions or milk
to counteract the acidity in the tear gas,
but the only truly effective rinse is with
diphoterine, which is a solution used to decontaminate
chemical splashes by neutralizing acids.
But who has access to THAT?
Another alarming issue with the use of tear
gas is that toxicology data is particularly
limited because much of the research being
done on it is military-based and therefore
classified.
Yikes!
Not only that, long term effects of exposure
is practically unknown.
There have been a some studies done to measure
short term and long term effects, but the
sample population in the experiments have
been rather small, which can lead to potential
systematic bias and error in measuring the
results.
However, the study did find that even after
ten months post exposure many reported that
they experienced respiratory issues like coughing
fits and worsening of asthma, decreased exercise
tolerance, and even ocular ulcers.
How do you feel about the over usage of tear
gas for crowd control?
Let us know in comment section below.
If you want to learn more about what’s going
in Ferguson, go check out our sister show,
TestTube.
And for more of my videos check out sourcefed
and sourcefednerd!
Thanks for watching.